en salud hablaremos del cierre de la
conferencia regional sobre la mujer que
fue organizada por el la cepal bajo el
lema de la sociedad del cuidado para una
recuperación sostenible con igualdad de
género se ha celebrado durante toda la
semana en Buenos Aires Argentina y lo ha
hecho para poner en el centro del debate
los trabajos y cuidados no remunerados
que realizan todos los días las mujeres
especialmente después de la pandemia
cuando vimos como ellas estuvieron al
frente de la línea de la batalla contra
el virus vamos a la ampliación y para
ello me acompaña a mi compañera Marina
sardina que tiene todos los detalles
Marina Buen día para usted y cuéntenos
sobre esta importante labor Buenos días
Ángela pues efectivamente la pandemia de
los cuidados no remunerados no cesa en
América Latina y no solo es un tema
económico también es un tema de salud
pública la desigualdad del trabajo del
cuidado en el interior de los hogares
repercute en la salud tanto física como
mental de las mujeres y niñas de la
región y agrava las con de pobreza o
precarización en los derechos básicos
Como por ejemplo el derecho a la
educación una brecha que precisamente se
puso sobre la mesa durante esta
conferencia Regional de la cepal veamos
unas cifras que ofrecieron durante la
conferencia las mujeres se emplean el
20% de su tiempo al trabajo doméstico y
de cuidados no remunerados las mujeres
dedican tres veces más así que los
hombres al trabajo doméstico y a estos
cuidados el 38% de las mujeres jóvenes
ni estudian y trabajan no
remuneradamente esto dicen que también
el 51% de la razón es que atienden las
responsabilidades del cuidado y
precisamente para hablar de esto tenemos
con nosotras a Maria Noel Baeza
directora regional para las Américas de
ONU Caribe lo primero buenas Muchas
gracias por estar con nosotras en
francés 24 María y quería preguntarte
qué es eso son estos trabajos Cómo
definimos estos trabajos no remunerados
estos trabajos del cuidado que hacen las
mujeres y Por qué es importante
reivindicarlos
muy buenos días Muchas gracias por
invitarme
mira lo importante de esta conferencia
es que se ha dedicado a cambiar a
proponer cambiar el modelo de desarrollo
y pasar a ser una sociedad del cuidado y
por qué una sociedad de Cuidado poner al
centro a las personas cuidado
necesitamos desde que nacemos hasta que
morimos es algo que es una tarea que se
hace no remuneradamente en el hogar en
el seno de la familia en la comunidad y
lo que nosotros hemos analizado
conjuntamente con la cepal desde Ono
mujeres que las dos organizaciones
estamos convocando esta conferencia que
está integrada por todas las ministras
de género de la región y más de 2000
mujeres de la sociedad civil esto es muy
importante porque el cuidado se entiende
de manera comunitaria de manera en el
hogar y es la actividad
más tiempo nos insume y por eso las
mujeres muchas veces no pueden trabajar
en la economía real porque tienen que
cuidar entonces lo que proponemos es la
creación de sistemas integrales de
Cuidado tanto público como privados como
comunitarios proponemos la gobernanza de
esos sistemas y proponemos el
financiamiento de estos sistemas o sea
proponemos pero también buscamos
soluciones y por qué nosotros
consideramos que es fundamental la
creación de trabajos de cuidado para la
reactivación económica de nuestra región
Por qué Porque es fundamental que las
mujeres puedan tener alternativas para
el bienestar de su familia para crear
empleo de calidad en lo que son los
cuidados y también para salir a trabajar
y poder aportar en la economía y
nosotros consideramos también que esto
es una gran previsión para las
violencias de género por qué porque una
mujer que tiene autonomía económica es
una mujer que no va a soportar a un
Depredador violento porque tiene salidas
de subida económica la tengo que
interrumpir porque nos estamos quedando
sin tiempo hay estudios que señalan que
el trabajo del hogar que realizan las
mujeres está asociado con mala salud
física y mental
Cuáles son esos efectos de desigualdad
de género que traen problemas a la salud
de las mujeres rápidamente
rápidamente el trabajo de Cuidado no
termina nunca Imagínate si estás
cuidando un adulto mayor o un
discapacitado es un trabajo que no no
tiene hora de finalización lo que
proponemos es reconocerlo que el trabajo
de Cuidado es un trabajo
redistribuirlo con los hombres y
proponemos la corresponsabilidad porque
es injusta Esta división sexual del
trabajo que solo las mujeres cuidan y
tercero reducirlo no Estas son las tres
erres que estamos proponiendo Y esa
corresponsabilidad esa redistribución
con los hombres del cuidado del trabajo
de cuidado y yo creo que es justo porque
el trabajo no remunerado de Cuidado es
muy Injusto y y atenta contra la
igualdad de las mujeres por eso es que
estamos proponiendo esta creación de
sistemas integrales de Cuidado claro
María y también es quien cuida de las
cuidadoras están los sistemas sanitarios
latinoamericanos preparados para cuidar
de las mujeres que nos están cuidando
bueno no lo están por eso estamos
proponiendo que el cuidado se convierta
una cuarta pata de la protección social
así como es educación salud y el la
seguridad social estamos proponiendo que
los cuidados sean esa cuarta pata no nos
olvidemos que la población
latinoamericana está envejeciendo
entonces cada vez va a necesitar más
cuidados en las personas adultas mayores
Entonces es algo que hoy tenemos que
discutirlo tenemos que decir cómo lo
vamos a hacer cómo lo vamos a financiar
Pero esto es un algo que está para para
quedarse en las sociedades y es
fundamental que así sea para la creación
de empleo para permitir el
empoderamiento de las mujeres y por
supuesto a la salud y no nos olvidemos
del autocuidado también las mujeres
cuidamos somos cuidadoras pero
necesitamos auto cuidarnos justamente
para protegernos de la Salud Mental y de
la salud en general no Entonces esto
Esta es la propuesta que va a salir hoy
de la conferencia estamos muy contentas
la conferencia maravillosamente bien y
hay una propuesta de un compromiso de
los países de trabajar estos temas y que
la brecha de género no siga afectando la
salud de las mujeres Gracias a ustedes
Marina gracias a la representante de una
mujeres y bueno es el momento de